[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi 19 septembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
il souffle sa trentième bougie le
village d'enfants sos de plaisir a fêté
son anniversaire ce week end
depuis sa création le lieu a accueilli
plus de 150 enfants réunis en fratrie
privé de cellule familiale nous recevons
à ce propos aurélie rôti chef de service
éducatif de sos villages d'enfants est
la soirée des réussites c'est le nom de
cet événement créé à trappes en 2004
chaque année la ville yvelinoise il
récompense sa jeunesse méritante sur le
plan scolaire artistiques
professionnelles ou sportifs
retour sur l'édition en 2017 enfin un
salon pour les fans de jeux vidéo la
première édition du montini games day se
tenait samedi dernier l'occasion de
jouer sur des consoles dernière
génération mais aussi de replonger
quelques années en arrière avant de
développer ces titres la mobilisation
des salariés de ces purs à thiverval
grignon environ 200 personnes hier ont
manifesté devant les locaux de la
société de traitement d'ordures
ménagères motifs protester contre le
licenciement abusif d'un de leurs
collègues
le syndicat fo du site avait appelé à
une grève illimitée
la semaine dernière reprise du travail
aujourd'hui un rendez-vous est fixé avec
la direction ce jeudi après la cgt la
semaine dernière nouvelle réunion des
changes ce soir au sujet de la loi
travail
cette fois ci c'est le mouvement du 1er
juillet qui organise ce rendez vous le
comité et d'elancourt du parti lancé par
liv linois benoît hamon propose la
rencontre à partir de 20 heures c'est à
la maison de quartier de villedieu
propos recueillis par lee arêches à la
fois les pouvoirs
apporter des éléments de clarification
sur les principaux axes de la loi
travail
et puisqu'elle va changer pour les les
français de manière assez concrète et
puis en même temps quel projet
alternatif nous on peut porter au niveau
du mouvement du 1er juillet puisqu'on a
évidemment un projet assez construit en
matière de de travail d'économie
d'emploi
donc l'idée c'est aussi de montrer qu'il
ya une alternative à ce qui est proposé
par le gouvernement
on reçoit sur ce plateau aurélie
rottiers bonsoir vous êtes chef de
service éducatif de l'association sos
villages d'enfants
justement le village d'enfants sos de
plaisir a fêté ses 30 ans ce samedi 16
septembre
ouvert depuis 1987 il accueille des
fratries dont le cadre de la protection
de l'enfance
je vous propose de regarder ce reportage
de nicolas landry jour de fête pour le
village d'enfants sos de plaisir un
anniversaire célébré avec tous les
acteurs de cette association présente
notamment marie claude engagé depuis
cinq ans au sos villages d'enfants elle
s'occupe actuellement de deux fratries
et deux autres enfants
quatre adolescentes de 14 à 18 ans deux
garçons de 9 et 10 ans on organise des
jeux on part en vacances ensemble
il ya beaucoup d'humour aussi sur la
maison c'est des enfants qui sont
remplis d'humour d'imagination et c'est
vrai qu'on s'amuse bien comme une maman
je m'occupe de tout ce qui concerne leur
bien-être la scolarité les soins les
loisirs comme une maman la cause des
enfants c'est une costume tient à coeur
j'ai tout le temps enfin l'enfant de
maintenance et l'adulte de demain
c'est peut-être aussi un côté politique
âgé de 20 ans julie bila est arrivé en
novembre 2005 avec ses cinq frères et
soeurs pendant les vacances scolaires on
allait souvent la famille même de notre
éducatrice familiale donc ça nous a
permis de faire partie de la famille
d'ailleurs on les appelle tout ce papier
mamie à tâtons tout ça m'a permis de
mieux grandir je pense que dans le cadre
de ma famille ça m'a permis de resserrer
les liens fraternels fraternelle mes
frères et soeurs on a un lien très
soudée le village d'enfants sos de
plaisir est situé dans le quartier de
l'aqueduc
quinze maisons disent occupés par des
familles 54 enfants sont accueillis
la mission de l'association conserver le
lien entre frères et soeurs pour les
enfants placés dans le cadre juridique
de la protection de l'enfance que tout
enfant quel qu'il soit quel que soit sa
situation
c'est là des frères et soeurs
ses frères et soeurs viennent là dans
l'histoire familiale et nous nous
privilégions cela ça me permet de
déconstruire en quelque sorte cette
histoire là pour mieux reconstruire
l'avenir en france près de 1000 enfants
vivent dans les 14 villages d'enfants
sos cette ong présentes dans 54 pays
dans le monde
aurélie aux routiers avec nous sur ce
plateau pour réagir à ce sujet et parler
de l'association sos villages d'enfants
le voyait dans ce reportage les enfants
sont accueillis sur ses villages en
fratrie on sent que ça revêt un
caractère primordial finalement de ne
pas être séparé de ses frères et soeurs
ah oui c'est une valeur vraiment a
soutenu par l'association sos villages
d'enfants
pour nous c'est les enfants qui vivent
un placement il ya quelque chose
d'extrêmement douloureux et c'est vrai
que les bases du projet soit ce village
d'enfance pour de pouvoir permettre aux
enfants de ne pas être séparé dans le
cadre d'un placement et de pouvoir
grandir ensemble
c'est leur noyau familial qui est
maintenu et qui sont ils ces enfants
sont des orphelins des enfants
abandonnés privé finalement 2-2 cellule
familiale
oui alors au niveau des visages
d'enfants on accueille principalement
des enfants qui sont placés donc sur des
longues durées donc qui déplaceront
judiciaire principalement des enfants
qui ont subi des maltraitances graves
on accueille également des enfants
pupille de l'état nous soit parce qu'il
ya eu une déchéance totale d'autorité
parentale soit parce qu'ils sont
simplement orphelins voilà donc au
niveau de la famille il ya un maintien
forcément des liens avec la famille dans
la mesure du possible mais en fonction
des droits qui sont accordés par le juge
des enfants et sur ce village ils vont
ils passer toute leur jeunesse commence
comment ça se passe ça va vraiment
dépendre des situations mais c'est vrai
qu'on a une durée de placement qui est
quand même assez longue sur de 70 sur le
village d'enfants de plaisir mais on a
des enfants qui peuvent rentrer à l'âge
de 2-3 ans et ressortir à la majorité
vend plus et comment déroule justement
leur passage sur place que vont-ils
pouvoir de quoi vont-ils pouvoir
bénéficier dans c dans ces villages sos
d'enfants alors vraiment l'important
c'est de pouvoir les aider à grandir et
à se construire malgré le parcours déjà
difficile qu'ils ont pu avoir avant le
placement
donc on va les aider à se reconstruire
et à grandir et essayer de mettre un
maximum de choses en place pour qu'il
puisse sortir et démarrer leur vie
d'adulte dans de bonnes conditions
alors après c'est surtout la base du
projet de l'association qui fait qu'on
ait un
l'installation de la protection en
france un peu particulière par rapport
aux valeurs qui sont défendues donc déjà
l'accueil des fratries puisque dans d'un
bon gros établissements la protection
enfance les enfants sont séparés
du coup leurs frais à leur sort que ça
fonctionne plus par groupe de deux
tranches d'âge donc nous on maintient
vraiment les frères et les soeurs
ensemble on essaye de faire les gens
ensemble au sein d'une même maison et on
défend un mode d'accueil de type
familial c'est à dire que au niveau d'un
village d'enfants vous allez avoir
différentes maisons ou vont travailler
du coup une mère sos et une aide
familiale en loum donc la mère sos va
vraiment être je dirais le relais
affectif pour l'enfant et bonbons shorts
finalement ces jeunes se voient là au
quotidien donc elle va travailler entre
trois et quatre semaines par mois et
après tu relayés pendant quelques jours
de repos par l'aide familiale et on va
vraiment essayer de leur offrir une vie
de type familial comme il aurait pu la
voir dans une famille ordinaire donc
allé à l'école du coin s'inscrire à des
sports pouvoir inviter des copains des
copines à la maison à mais chez d'autres
enfants essayait vraiment de leur part
d'avoir une chambre une petite maison
comme tout enfant est d'être sur quelque
chose de très très familial
c'est important pour nous quatorze
villages sos dans toute la france vous
le dis j'ai toujours car si elle arrive
il est en cours de construction et donc
bien bien parmi ces 15 villages celui de
plaisir 57 fat fratrie ont été
accueillis sur ce village depuis 1987 ça
représente environ 153 enfants
quel est le but au final quand le jeune
va sortir de ce village quand il va
arriver à sa vie de jeune adulte qui est
ce qui fait finalement que vous dites
voilà j'ai réussi ma mission pour le
lancer dans la vie finalement qu'est ce
qui vous fait dire ça on a pu voir dans
le reportage quand on voit julie je
pense que
voilà c'est un peu le résultat tout ça
c'est toute l'énergie qui est mis au
quotidien auprès de ses enfants et eux
aussi toute l'énergie et la force qui
vont aller puiser pour pouvoir avancer
dans la vie et puis quitté le village
avec avec un toit avec un travail ou et
du coup on va démarrer une nouvelle vie
pour eux et importants
on peut s'imaginer au moment des au
moment où le jeune type le village peut
être un déchirement avec la meilleure
espèce mais aussi une fierté peut-être
du devoir accompli
on peut on peut parler de fierté aussi
y'a jamais déchaînement parce qu'il ya
toujours un maintien des liens une mère
sos généralement il ya tellement
d'implication de sa part puisqu'elle
accompagne quand même les enfants dans
la durée qui a toujours un maintien du
lien avec les jeunes vont revenir sur le
village qui façon spontanément pour
l'avoir et les a invité à son mariage
enfin venir montrer leurs propres
enfants il ya toujours un maintien du
lien avec le vivien est créé pour toute
la vie oui oui
dernière question 30 ans pour ce village
sos d'enfants à plaisir qu'est ce qu'on
peut lui souhaiter
d'aller au 40e je pense ça sera une
bonne chose voire plus à de continuer on
va s'agrandir et à de continuer à
accueillir des enfants et que l'ensemble
de l'équipe puisse puisse continuer à
aider de nombreux enfants
merci aurélie rottiers d'avoir le rappel
chef de service éducatif à l'association
sos villages d'enfants
et pour plus d'informations sur
l'association et ses villages vous
pouvez consulter le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran 13 ans
qu'elle existe la soirée des réussites
2017 a eu lieu à trappes créé en 2004
elle récompense les jeunes méritants de
la ville yvelinoise cette année 150
trappistes ont été ainsi distingués pour
leur succès scolaire professionnel
artistique ou sportif mélanie poquet sur
des images de michael et demi d'euros
ils ont eu une mention au brevet et au
bac sont devenus infirmiers se sont
illustrés comme sportif où se sont
engagé dans l'humanitaire
vendredi soir c'est trappistes ont été
récompensés par la ville lors de la
soirée des réussites sont contents dit
d'être ici et savoir que tout le travail
que j'ai fait bah au moins ils devraient
compenser je crois fait ça que c'est
coiffé sa revanche
c'est quand même valorisant de ba de
pouvoir déjà partager sa réussite avec
les autres et de voir que battre ap
il ya beaucoup de jeunes comme ça et
c'est réussi on a commencé la première
soirée des réussites avec une
quarantaine de jeunes
nous en sommes là à 150 sans avoir
changé les niveaux et les critères qui
font qu'on a une récompense au sens
noble du terme à cette soirée de la
russie
cette année la soirée était parrainée
par ahmed agne fondateur et directeur
éditorial de qui ou une maison d'édition
de manga bonjour du match alors parlé un
petit peu de mon parcours
qu'est ce que je fais sans m'ériger en
modèle pour pour autant parce que je
pense qu'il ya pas un modèle de réussite
il ya plein de manières de envisager son
avenir personnel et professionnel et
voilà le mien sont nés un parmi d'autres
et j'espère que certains d'entre eux
peut-être prouvons quelconque
inspiration ovadia elle les lauréats se
sont vu remettre ce soir là un
ordinateur portable encore des bons
d'achat depuis sa création en 2004 plus
de 2000 jeunes ont été récompensés
toujours à trappes des éducateurs
spécialisés dans les collèges le village
youri gagarine et gustave courbet comme
dans neuf autres établissements des
yvelines jugé sensible ils sont mandatés
par le conseil départemental depuis la
rentrée leur mission renforcer la
prévention auprès des jeunes et faire le
lien avec les parents et les dispositifs
locaux
c'est ce dispositif est testé pendant un
an et nous vous parlions hier des
chéquiers avantage aux opérations
lancées à maurepas pour booster le
commerce local
cela pourrait aider par exemple cette
nouvelle boutique le coin de sommelier
inauguré ce la semaine dernière pardon
c'est une aubaine pour le dynamisme du
centre ville patrick jacques de dixmude
et les arrêts ch des journaux des
magazines du vin et de la charcuterie
dans une même boutique c'est possible et
c'est le pari que se sont lancé hugo
roux et son père avec le sommelier du
coin avant de s'implanter il a fallu
étudier le potentiel du quartier on a vu
que 74 % de la population des marques
bazian souhaité avoir un caviste
bach dans le centre de mort paille qui
est un centre à ces papas délabrée mais
on va dire à partir de 17 heures le soir
il n'y a plus personne qui a réuni à que
des banques
donc notre objectif avec cette étude de
marché c'était prendre le pari de
redynamiser ce centre est de pouvoir
avoir un moment convivial avec les gens
qu'ils puissent venir partager un moment
convivial entre un bon verre de vin une
belle assiette de charcuterie et qu'ils
puissent remporter chez eux de bons
souvenirs ils étaient près de 150
amateurs et curieux à l'inauguration de
ce double commerce inédit l'idée aussi
qu'on est ce de type de commerce dont un
nouveau qui n'existait pas sur maurepas
et qui est une offre toute particulière
donc qui je l'espère va voilà aussi
avoir un rayonnement au-delà de maurepas
et bénéficier avec le dynamisme de la
presse donc c'est une bonne idée et
c'est aussi un service de proximité
parce que nous avons une population
aussi qui les ignore pas redynamiser le
centre ville et ses commerces une
priorité pour la ville pour mon rôle
aussi en tant que maire avec mon
adjointe au commerce c'est de travailler
avec les propriétaires de voir avec eux
quels sont les loyers qu'ils pourraient
faire de négocier aussi avec eux pour
que les loyers souvent doivent aller à
la baisse pour éviter qu'on ait des
banques ou des agences immobilières
encore qui viennent s'installer en
centre-ville amour pas le taux de
vacance est inférieur à 10% selon la
municipalité
vous l'avez sans doute ressenti le temps
est beaucoup plus frais ces derniers
jours et la baisse des températures
impacte directement les personnes sans
abri qui souffrent de cette baisse des
températures pour leur venir en aide
l'opération pièce rouge vient d'être
lancé pour récolter des fonds pour en
parler avec nous rachid farhi bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le fondateur et le
président de l'association élan
solidarité et vélizy qui est à
l'initiative
à l'origine de cette initiative première
question toute simple toute simple
pourquoi lancer l'opération pièce rouge
en fait l'opération ps rouget et est le
moyen le plus simple pour nous
de récolter des fonds en fait afin
d'aider les sens appelant directement on
se dit comment on peut récolter des
fonds en faisant participer le maximum
de la population et on se dit bon les
pièces rouges qui encombrent
généralement nous nos poches
si on est le moyen idéal pour pour aider
les sans abri mais les pièces rouges ça
fait référence bien sûr au ps 2 1 de 5
centimes mais on peut on peut n'être
autre d'autres pièces ou même des
billets dans ses yeux
bien sûr ceci étant la première au
prince ce qu'on a fait avec on a pu
récolter environ 45 kg de pièces rouges
qui représente pas loin de 400 euros
et eux ce qui prouve bien que les
petites pièces de 1 2 ou 5 centimes pour
nous et un est un gain énorme pour le la
suite de l'assaut alors si on parle de
votre parcours vous êtes sapeurs
pompiers professionnels d evelyne
également athlètes de haut niveau
comment on peut-on expliquer votre
engagement finalement pour les sans-abri
ça vient d'où cet engagement bon en fait
tout ça toute franchise
c'est devenu réellement sous un tas de
conscience lors d'un des entraînements
cet hiver l'hiver dernier ouzou
participé à la séance de côté j'ai eu
les mains tellement congé je n'arrivais
pas à faire mon lacet et l'ajustement de
conscience qui me dit mais comment sont
les gens qui vivent dehors
le fait que je sois sapeurs pompiers ou
athlète n'avait n'a pas de n'a pas de
lien dans l'aide des sans abri et c'est
en fait ça m'est venu réellement comme
ça au jour d'aujourd'hui
j'appelle mal expliqué d'accord mais
c'est une expérience personne alors
l'opération pièce rouge a été inaugurée
le 9 septembre dernier lancement
officiel en présence du maire de vélizy
pascal thévenot c'était lors du forum
des associations en présence également
de la direction des pompiers des
yvelines
de quelle manière ces fonds que vous
avez récolté que vous allez récolter
vont bon petit pouvoir aider les
sans-abri ça va servir concrètement à
quoi bon bah tout simplement le premier
projet qu'on a réellement pour les sans
abri c'est de pouvoir nous déjà avant
un moyen de locomotion pour pouvoir les
aider donc c'est une opération parce
qu'on va le permettre d'une part d'avoir
ce premier moyen de déplacement mais
surtout de pouvoir en fait créer des
kits hygiène donc faut savoir que les
kits hygiène c'est ça représente environ
5 euros par kit et par personne ce qui
fait qu'on pourra au moins leur donner
le maximum de dignité à la valeur
humaine
ça c'est une importance de la dignité de
pouvoir rester propre c'est quelque
chose de primordial qui aussi aide au
quotidien
c'est exactement ça une personne qui vit
dans la rue malheureusement là tous les
inconvénients de de ce qui se passe dans
la rue et le fait que nous on leur
apporte en fait ceux se ses dignité
humaine ce qui est perdu et qui plaît
aux sons de la personne va leur
permettre de peut-être mieux subir su
bien les dangers nous avions alors
concrètement comment comment fait-on
pour donner de l'argent vous voyez vous
avez parlé de d'urnes qui peuvent être
disponibles dans plusieurs endroits est
ce que à l'instar de la l'opération
pièces jaunes par exemple on peut
récupérer son noeud en effet rossi notre
collecte dans une école dans notre
entreprise dans notre club de sport ah
oui en fait on justement néant avec le
sdi 78 donc les sapeurs pompiers le
service départemental
on va mettre cette opération au sein du
département des yvelines
le maire monsieur tve nous a autorisé la
mise en place des tirelires au sein des
commerces et de la ville de vélizy
encore et on a plein de petits projets
justement en espérant que la région va
nous soutenir dans ce projet de mettre
des détails à lire un peu partout dans
la région
l'idée c'est lui donner peut-être un
écho voulait dit départementales
régionales voir un jour national peut
être cesser votre souhait c'est notre
souhait va c'est le fait que es v veut
mettre en place est réellement d'aider
les maximums de sans abri dia dans la
région mais pourquoi pas être comme la
croix-rouge à jour c'est l'autre silo de
but de pouvoir démarrer tout petit
peut-être un jour pouvoir être grande en
là dans la société française et d'avoir
le soutien du maire de vélizy des
pompiers désir
du conseil départemental c'est j'imagine
a aussi important pour lui donner donner
de l'élan donné de l'écho à ce projet
set initial
pour moi c'est super important que
monsieur thévenoud le maire de vélizy
nous soutiennent on a aussi le soutien
du député monsieur bart aussi qu'ils ont
besoin de rien l'euro
bien évidemment il est de la deuxième
circonscription des élus est
complètement je me suis entretenu
longuement avec lui on a le soutien des
directeurs départementaux
sapeurs-pompiers de chez nous mais aussi
en france qui a atteint 2 qu'une chose
que le développement chez les pompiers
l'opération parce que je passe bien pour
pouvoir mettre tout ça au niveau
national lens est donc le 9 septembre
dernier jusqu'à quand peut-on donner
pour cet opéra on a trois trois
événements majeurs qui arrive donc le
vide greniers de vélizy on aura là notre
tirelire
on aura le running back de vélizy donc
ce sont des événements sportifs
d'enlever les i et le 10 km de vélizy où
on aura sept 7 bat cette tirelire géante
qu'il va en voir aider les sans abri et
poursuivre bien sûr toute l'actualité et
suivre ses rendez-vous ne pas manquer ce
rendez vous pouvez vous rendre sur la
page facebook de l'élan solidarité
vélizy qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
pour nos téléspectateurs merci à farid
rachid ancien président et fondateur des
lans solidarité versailles l'association
organise l'opération pièces rouges en
faveur des personnes sans abri plus
d'informations je les 10,1 sur la page
facebook de l'association
côté culture c'est une scène célèbre et
mythique le théâtre montansier de
versailles fait sont deux cent
quarantième anniversaire
au programme des conférences des
lectures des représentations et une
exposition
elle a débuté ce week-end à l'occasion
des journées du patrimoine
reportage de mélanie poker
le théâtre montansier c'est avant tout
une histoire de femmes
la première marguerite brunet dit
mademoiselle montansier elle crée ce
théâtre qui prendra son nom inaugurée le
18 novembre 1777 parle de 16 c'est un
théâtre qui est la particularité d'être
entre la ville et la cour c'est ce qui
fait sa spécificité il est d'abord
situer géographiquement entre la ville
de versailles et le parc du château
et il accueille au sein du public à la
fois des membres de la cour et des
versaillais qui viennent assister à une
programmation extrêmement riche
près de 180 objets retrace l'histoire de
ce lieu peut être moins connu que
l'opéra royal ou le petit théâtre de la
reine des documents d'époque issus des
collections de la ville dont une lettre
écrite durant la révolution
dans cette lettre au moment où la
montansier est en prison elle essaie de
se justifier auprès dès révolutionnaires
et elle va inventer prétendre qu'elle a
était révolutionnaire avant la lettre en
accueillant les parisiennes au théâtre
de versailles durant les journées
d'octobre le 20e siècle est lui aussi
marqué par une femme marcelle
tassencourt qui le dirigera avec son
mari thierry monnier de 1961 à 1992
marcel tassencourt était à la fois
comédienne metteur en scène elle a été
vraiment une passeuse de théâtre à
versailles en étant à la fois la
directrice du théâtre elle a enseigné au
conservatoire et la forme et un certain
nombre d'élèves qui sont aujourd'hui
assez assez célèbre certains comédiens
d'autres noms comme françois de mazières
l'actuel maire de versailles ou bien
encore muriel mayette qui dirige
villa médicis à rome le théâtre
montansier se dévoile à travers ses
programmations ses succès ses scandales
ou encore ces rénovations
un anniversaire fêté aux archives
communales de la ville
mario kart sonic tomb raider ces noms
vous évoque sûrement et des souvenirs
d'enfance le retro gaming est l un des
sept pôles proposé au premier salon à
montigny à games day qui se tenait
samedi dernier au centre sportif de
médecine et le bretonneux
un événement pour les amateurs de jeux
en tout genre nicolas landry et aurélie
rose
[Applaudissements]
être concentré être habile avec ses
doigts
voilà les secrets pour emporter une
partie de fifa le célèbre jeu de
football sur console s'est invité à la
première édition du montigny games des
trente personnes étaient inscrites pour
ce challenge et c'est donc gilles
moretton qui a été le meilleur
recrutement c'est cool c'est la première
fois devient un événement comme ça
jamais fait donc franchement ce qu'il
coule jamais y en aura d'autres en plus
des jeux sur console les visiteurs
avaient accès à des jeux d'arcade de
simulation en passant par le
traditionnel baby foot ou le retrogaming
l'événement se voulait inter
générationnelle on a vu aujourd'hui en
fait les familles entières venir donc
c'est ça qui est important parce que des
pans peut avoir
des parents qui viennent ou les enfants
mais là toute la famille est venue
ensemble pour venir jouer chacun trouvé
son gérer son jeu delphine et gilles
sont venus en famille et ont pu
effectuer un petit retour vers le passé
ah oui
[Musique]
non rappelle beaucoup de souvenirs de au
sénat de l'essence l'adolescence de
grandes soirées passées devant les
consoles et à l'époque on pouvait pas
terminer on ne peut pas enregistrer bien
ses souvenirs les enfants maintenant il
enregistre et continue lendemain après
ce que nous quand ça s'arrêtait ça
s'arrêtait cette première édition du
montigny games des initiés par le
conseil municipal des jeunes semblent
avoir tenu toutes ses promesses en
faisant le bonheur des amateurs de jeux
un mot de sport avant de se quitter
comme tous les mois de septembre depuis
1971 le tennis club du grand versailles
organise son traditionnel open un
tournoi qui marquait la fin de la saison
cette année quatre cent quatre-vingt
seize joueurs s'affrontent sur neuf
cours depuis le 6 septembre dernier et
les finales sont programmées ce dimanche
24 septembre
on écoute le directeur sportif du club
au micro de tv 78
tout au long du tournoi on voit une
évolution du niveau même si le niveau
amateur c'est voir la confrontation
entre deux deux joueurs c'est très
intéressant mais au fur et à mesure du
tournoi on voit le jeu s'accélérer on
voit moins de fautes
c'est un peu plus dense et plus plus
solide ça va plus vite
comme à la télé c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal merci de l'avoir suivi ripley il
reportage à retrouver sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]